as I said I'm working on several other  works now I have eight pages in that new  piece of work that reminds you how to  become a child it's funny that's good  yeah it's funny they give us a lot a  little spoiler a little bubble gum ice  cream  it's like you know I'm sorry I love  California but like seriously those  brownies are horrible like you know the  the ones with what Chia and like sand  and who wants that  have fun enjoy life right I'm by the way  I'm not saying go all the way to the  other extreme mmm only brownies and ice  cream no no but but but but but you know  when was the last time you ran around  with your children in a park or with  your friends in a park where when did  you actually go to the gym to enjoy it  right we go to the gym to deliver  another target it's really weird like  we're running an algorithm rather than  enjoying the problem yeah we we forgot  about joy we are so driven so driven we  are so self-critical  we are so unhappy with where we are